[Music]
so very recently during the whole Harvey
Weinstein scandal Weinstein was compared
to a hyena and this is one of those
instances where I just sort of shook my
head and just thought well that is just
about the most least appropriate animal
to compare how Harvey Weinstein - you
know the reason why I think it was the
New York Times that was comparing Harvey
Weinstein to a hyena was because they
are seen as these you know aggressive
unpleasant cowardly malicious malevolent
creatures the truth about hyenas is that
they are really I think more like the
feminist icons of the animal kingdom
they are the spotted hyena is an
extraordinary creature they are the
original chicks with dicks because they
have extraordinary genitalia the
female's genitalia is a facsimile of the
male's she has what is described in
polite zoological circles as a pseudo
penis
which is actually an 8 inch clitoris and
she also has a fake scrotum and it's
it's it's an unusual piece of equipment
for a female because it's a sort of
strange multitasking organdy it's the
pseudo penis because the female hyena
will actually copulate urinate and give
birth through it so giving birth is a
bit like squeezing a melon out of a hose
pipe and one in I think is a large
percentage of of Cubs
suffocate on the way out and the large
amounts of time mums die in childbirth
so you got to think hello evolution what
were you thinking when when you evolved
the pseudo penis in Lahaina what can
possibly what what possible reason can
there be for this structure and there
are lots of theories as to why
but the the likely that the most favored
theory by K whole camp who's the kind of
jane goodal of spotted hyenas amazing
scientists he's been studying them in
the world for years and years and years
when i asked her she said that she
thought that it was all to do with the
war between the sexes so hyenas are
unusual the females they don't just have
a pseudo penis and a fake scrotum but
they're also bigger than the males and
they're more aggressive hyena society is
a strict matriarchy with dominance
passing down the female line males are
reduced to the very outskirts of society
where they are forced to beg for
acceptance food and sex so the females
are really running the show and they're
extremely aggressive now if a male wants
to mate with a female it's almost
impossible for him to do that without
her cooperation because it's it's kind
of like trying to have sex with a sock
because he's got to try and insert his
erect actual penis into her half foot
floppy pseudo penis I mean it's not it's
not a tarted you can't really do it
unless the female is on your side now
within mammals amongst mammals rape is
not uncommon dolphins
everybody loves them look like they're
smiling and not averse to buffing each
other's blowholes or actually you know
that there's actually you know a fair
amount of non-consensual sex shall we
say that happens amongst dolphins and
you know but but for the for the female
hyena there's absolutely no way that the
male can force himself on her
because she has to be completely
compliant in order for him to be able to
mate with her so the idea that Harvey
Weinstein was described as a hyena
when these the this is a this is an
animal that is a strict make matriarchy
an aggressive female with a built-in
anti
device is is is about the most ludicrous
thing I've ever heard
[Music]